أنابيب لامعة بها عدد قليل من
الألواح المضيئة هنا وهناك يصعب
تخيل أن مكانًا هادئًا جدًا ولا يزال
بإمكانه إحداث ثورة في
مستقبل الطاقة في الشرق الأوسط وما وراءه ،
هذا هو أول إنتاج هيدروجين أخضر على نطاق صناعي
في الشرق الأوسط
وشمال إفريقيا
الهيدروجين هو غاز عديم اللون ، وهو العنصر الأكثر
وفرة
على الأرض ، وهو موجود دائمًا تقريبًا
كجزء من مركب آخر مثل الماء
من أجل إنتاج الطاقة ،
يحتاج الهيدروجين إلى استخراجه من الوقود الأحفوري
الكتلة الحيوية أو الماء اليوم 95 من
إنتاج الهيدروجين يعتمد على الوقود الأحفوري
ولكن هناك أكثر خضرة  خيارات
تغذي العملية بمصادر
طاقة متجددة مثل طاقة الرياح والطاقة الشمسية
وهذا ما يعنيه الهيدروجين الأخضر في
هذا المصنع في دبي توفر الألواح الشمسية
الطاقة لتقسيم الماء إلى هيدروجين
ويتم إطلاق الأكسجين في الهواء
ويتم تخزين الهيدروجين لاستخدامه
لاحقًا  وتحويلها إلى كهرباء
أثناء الليل ، تعد
هذه القدرة على التخزين مكافأة إضافية
لا تتمتع بها الشمس  لا تتألق الرياح
دائمًا ولا تهب الرياح دائمًا ، مما يؤدي إلى
انخفاض موثوقية استخدام الهيدروجين الأخضر
حيث يتم فتح تخزين طاقة طويل الأمد بكثافة عالية منذ
أكثر من عام بقليل
يتم تغذيته حاليًا في مزيج الطاقة في دبي ،
فنحن نأخذ الهيدروجين المخزن ونحن
احرقها وننتج حوالي 280 كيلو واط من
الكهرباء ونقوم بتزويدها بالشبكة
وهذا يكفي لتزويد أقل بقليل من 10
منازل أمريكية في المتوسط ​​يوميًا ولكن
هناك خطط لتوسيع نطاق المشروع
وزيادة الإنتاج هناك طلب كبير في المستقبل
على السيارة و  لاستخدامها في
النقل أيضًا ، يمكننا أيضًا
تصديرها غدًا إلى البلدان التي تريد
الطاقة ،
لا يزال هناك طريق طويل أمامنا
تم استثمار أكثر من 13 مليار دولار في
هذا المصنع التجريبي وقد يكون إنتاج الهيدروجين
نفسه باهظ التكلفة حاليًا ،
حيث يتكلف ما بين 3 و  6.5 دولار للكيلوغرام ،
لذلك نأمل أن يكون هذا الرقم
أقل من دولار واحد لكل كيلوغرام
في الوقت الحالي ، لا يزال مستقبل الهيدروجين الأخضر
في الهواء ولكنه هادئ مثله
يبدو أن هذه التكنولوجيا تحدث بعض
الضجيج في مناقشة مستقبل
الطاقة
Eleni jokas CNN